foreign
[Music]
yes it is an intentional Trilogy it all
stem from my desire to explore the
themes of Abandonment the complexities
the Dynamics of abandonment
you know and not just the act of being
abandoned but the experience of not
being recognized of not being accepted
for who you are I think that that's such
an inherently Human Experience it's in
terms of the Aesthetics it's very
striking to look at so visually how then
is this format that you've chosen
conveying those themes of Abandonment or
isolation for us it was very important
to to find
the compositions and in this case is the
aspect ratio that could enhance the
sense of Suffocation and codependence
that is such an important part of of you
know the inner life of Monica but also
the relationships and um and so you know
the aspect ratio of this film is
actually very square like it's like 1.2
to 1.
and uh it's uh it's very similar to the
aspect ratio of um of portrait
photography and in fact it's one that
privileges
um
the body and the face over the landscape
and it also allowed us to work a lot
with the relationship between what is
inside the frame and what is outside of
the frame and so to to Really
allow The Spectator to or to excite the
imagination of The Spectator by
um often keeping some information or
hiding some information
I want to return to that a bit more when
we start talk about the performance a
bit more but for trace and Patricia when
did you become aware of this project and
what made you want to be a part of it
I think I got the script in December of
2016 and then auditioned shortly after
that
[Music]
um
and it was just a slow boil I know we
talked at length about the script and
I gave some notes and
um auditioned some more and then
and then yeah we just decided to do this
and then this lovely lady
I had met um oh I was about to use my
theater voice but I have a microphone
um uh
I had met Andrea to to Marrakesh and we
had talked about working together many
years before and and
um but then I got this offer
Trace was attached and he came to me and
um I I got a call from my agent saying
you've been offered this Andrea paloro
movie I said yes I did I didn't I say
yes in a day yes it was amazing because
actually you were on your way to LA and
then we met at the Chateau but I said
yes basically in a day
and um and and then I I met this
gorgeous woman it's all history so yeah
I'm very lucky
we are very lucky
so 2016 traces when you first heard
about the project so it obviously took a
while to come together what were some of
the like when you took it out to the
world and said this is a film I'm trying
to make what kind of reaction was there
or how how difficult was it to get
financing we won't get too far into that
because it's probably not interesting
for everyone but but yeah
we were attached for what several years
yeah so no of course and that's how long
it took to find the financing uh you
know to make it happen you know and it's
a very low budget film you know but
still
um you know it was a very very difficult
road but we managed to to to make it and
thanks to to the belief and the support
of course of our incredible cast of
trees
were actually here in in the room
generous
yeah and Christina sibo also
[Applause]
was that lengthy time then an advantage
then in terms of building up your
characters and getting to know each
other and developing the script further
with your cast attached to it
well I I would say just one thing about
that because I while you are living
through you know the weight of course
it's uh it says excruciating you know
it's very difficult and it's it's a very
debilitating as well but I have to say
that in retrospect
um it allowed us to get to know one
another
to develop a sense of intimacy and Trust
so anyway
yeah I guess that was the positive was
that we got to do a lot of dinners
and notes and dinners and
a pandemic dinner
no
um
and then I think we had a break in the
pandemic kind of
that summer in Cincinnati
um it was really hot in Cincinnati but I
had such a good time because I grew up
in Dayton 45 minutes north so in a lot
of ways the film was Full Circle for me
there was so many parallels
was it was a very strong
autobiographical aspect to it then or
was it more yeah I mean I'm hesitant to
use that word because she was definitely
a character I mean her show was
different from mine
um I feel like
her family like you know where where she
grew up even though it was a similar
area it was she grew up under different
circumstances than me
um so once I had this shell kind of
figured out of who she was the heart was
already there because of some of the
parallels in her journey and
um
just
a lot of that was already innate
um but it was just figuring out how to
deliver that and deliver that with
not so much dialogue which the you know
there there was no there was no easy
scenes there was no easy days it was all
really internal and
um trying to get everything across
um when there wasn't always the words
to use
yeah well that's really what struck me
is that
um there isn't a lot of dialogue I mean
there's things with a lot of dialogue
but what people are talking about is not
really what the scenes are about
necessarily
um and I think in that ways it subverts
conventions in that there's no big drama
scene with people breaking down and
tears apologizing or doing that kind of
stuff so so
um but it's all just conveyed
beautifully in I guess non-verbal
aspects of the performance so as a
director and writer why did you choose
to take that approach what about that
particularly appeals to you
well I think as a as a spectator also
Cinema
um as a cinephile I I adore
the moments in cinema where you can
penetrate and the emotional and
psychological inner world of a character
and that often happens without words
just observing a character or following
them you know by themselves you know in
in a space by themselves and those are
the moments that I've always been drawn
to
um and that they come natural to me to
to want to recreate them on the big
screen as a filmmaker as well but that's
actually I think one of the most
extraordinary thing about Cinema is you
know the the ability to photograph the
thoughts the emotions of a character
like you know I've done so much work and
so much work and in this industry and um
God should I just take a break uh anyway
and uh but I think with Andrea it was
learning a somewhat a
for me it was such a challenge it was a
different a slightly different language
in cinema for me and he's such a
beautiful and character-driven director
and
and tough and specific but you had to
navigate uh
with so few words and you had to be so
present and it it took me on a very
different Journey than I've had as as an
actor and I've had so many and worked
with so many directors in this industry
but Andrea brought me to a new place but
I want to go back to quickly to this
when we were talking about all the
dinners we had
and one of the great things that came
out of the dinner was Eugenia had dog I
was supposed to have two dogs but in the
process of us having all these dinners
Andrea got to know my dog is a daughter
and one day he goes
I love easy
why don't we use easy
because he had gotten to know my dog my
dog was always with me and and so that's
the the great thing about this my
beautiful dog ended up in the film
well is that where all the puppies were
the puppies well
was there a significance to the puppies
and
of course you know like you know it's a
there are a lot of reasons for it but
but it really uh ended up being a
significant scene the one in which
you know the the nephew you know brings
the puppy to his grandmother you know
like this new one she is actually dying
and you know she's sick yeah
um well going back to what you're seeing
Patricia about sort of getting the the
trust and that level of intimacy and
almost like learning a new language
um let's talk specifically about the
bathtub scene which is the one that
kills me every time I see it
um how would you how did you go about
sort of from what was on the page to
Preparing that scene to then actually
delivering the scene can you give some
insight into that process
I I it
I I had that scene
in me from the moment I read the script
I knew
but I came to love trace of the love I
have for Trace
off camera
and the love I have for Monica
eventually on camera are one
it's very simple
and we can only create so much as actors
and at some point
we have to just be completely honest
with ourselves
and
uh it's about your child is your child
is your child it's about unconventional
unconditional love and I
I had unconditional love
for Trace
and I just gave it to her on screen it
was I think uh
as simple as as that
and but I was lucky because
I had um
her I had a deep emotional connection to
her
from the moment I met the moment I met
the moment we met each other remember it
was at a preemie party
and you walked up to me and I
oh my God
I'm gonna play this gorgeous woman's
mother
with no makeup and dying
what Trace how was that moment for you
because your character is a bit reticent
sort of if I make eye contact in that so
how
what was your process in terms of not
wanting to sort of immediately give in
to what Patricia was giving you
it was a lot of it was a really complex
emotion and I don't
I tried not to
[Music]
um
what's the word I'm looking for it
wasn't until I saw it
played back that I really understood
what what I was feeling
um
and I think that's for the best because
I was really there in the moment and it
wasn't
um
I wasn't trying to like pre-package it
or overthink it I was just really there
with with Patty and that's for me it's
like when you drop into the truth of
whatever whatever character whatever
scene you know that's
that's how you make it feel real
yep so Andrea for you as a director
seeing that happen do you just back off
yes yeah absolutely actually
um you know there are some moments in
this film where uh in the production of
this film in the making of the film
where you know
I was I felt in such oh you know of what
uh you know
Patty and Trace were gifting me you know
like it was like you know it's
extraordinary as a director when you
know you are surprised you're Amazed by
what your collaborators are doing uh and
I have to say that for our whole crew
you know that's
a moment that we will not forget and we
keep talking about it you know like it's
uh it's a moment where like we were all
experiencing something together as we
were watching them and uh it was a
communal breathing in a way like and
there was everyone was like just let go
and there were so many people crying and
and it was a really extraordinary moment
that will stay with me forever
we had an extraordinary crew in
Cincinnati and I
I think we should just we always have to
talk we had really I think one of the
best Crews I've ever
worked with and again I've done a lot of
work and um
and just one of the most remarkable
beautiful Crews all the way around we
were they were so near and dear to all
of us and I think it helped
helped get the film made and have this
emotional breadth that it had it was
clear they were all there because they
believed so much in what we were doing I
mean no one was being paid
I mean it enough to get by
and it was during covert as well was
that correct so you have that adding to
the insular or the community nature of
it all
um
so just going back to what you were
saying about the framing was very
specific of the shots and that how was
it I mean did you shoot variations on
shots or were you very much like no this
is what we're doing no we we didn't
um you know and many many scenes were
shot in a single
um in in one you know like it was it was
the language of the film and I really
didn't give myself a lot of options in
the editing room I mean I knew
how I wanted this to be and we spent a
lot of time composing the images you
know like creating meaning through you
know the the use of lines through the
colors the light but uh also the the
bodies you know how they play with with
one another and and of course you know
allowing the performances to be the
guiding point in all of this so as as
performers then did you find that uh an
asset then to know sort of where your
boundary was I guess visually or was
that
um it was challenging challenge
very specific
um but I when I watched it back you know
and he and he explained to me
explain to me
um but there were times when I just felt
like
I wish I would have known they were on
the back of my head as I'm bawling my
eyes out in the car or you know but
my job is to act
and find the truth and
um and to trust so that was a lesson I
learned with this
this guy no I there were days
he was you know and and Izzy I had lift
Izzy up up get her I'm like well again
she's not a show dog she's just my dog
something and you know they're very very
specific frames and but suddenly within
that
framework
you found a release
and a comfort because the it was very
specific and it was
quite freeing oddly in in a strange way
um and it made sense in terms of the way
the story unfolded well because the the
relay of information was restricted by
the frame but also
everything sort of parceled out very
gradually which I kind of liked in a way
so you're putting together the pieces
and sorry this isn't really a question
it's just an observation but but I love
that way of like the sort of the world
opens up as you learn more and more and
I felt like that
sort of was a bit like Monica's Journey
as well
um one thing I noticed is that I felt
like the real connection the first real
connection Monica had throughout the
film was with the children
um and that seemed to be one time when
uh the character was really able to just
be herself or just Express Joy with no
sort of
um
ramifications or not being worried about
how I was going to cross was that um
intentional or
yes yes absolutely in fact you know the
film ends you know with that
relationship you know like you know
Monica like is looking at their nephew
you know as a you know as like maybe one
of the most genuine relationships that
she's had but also as a way to look at
the future you know like maybe with the
hope that he might not have to you know
endure the same difficulties you know
and go and have the same obstacles that
she she had
um within the context of society you
know like the national anthem in that
context is is really like you know is to
understand how Society has
you know it's it's has a way to actually
he's one of the main uh sources of of
our uh
like difficulties in in in or in the
structure of dealing with one another
yeah
yeah um and this is also a rarity it's
one of the few films centered on a trans
character that's not about the
transition process
um Trace how rare was that for you to
read a script that was
this sort of focus as opposed to
the actual transition process
yeah so rare I don't even know if I can
remember
I don't even know if I can remember a
film where they Center the trans
character in the title character and
we don't focus on the transition I mean
there's one scene of me
you know doing some estrogen in my leg
but other than that I mean it's
it's about this journey it's about this
family it's about
this kind of linear story with her mom
how much time we have left
um I mean that was probably the thing
that grabbed me first was like oh the
movie's called Monica and I would be
playing Monica if I can if I can land
this role you know I mean for me as a
trans actor
once in a lifetime
[Music]
foreign